there's a bit of a Charlie's Angels vibe
in the sense of you got these three
women and then you got Nick Fury who's
like a Bosley
what's going on there citizens of the
reject Nation we got ourselves a trailer
representing us three men the Marvels
today joined of course with John John
good morning how's your six in the
morning going that's so good I'm ready
for everyone to agree with my opinion
today John is not here you're a koi koi
last name yes yes I tried making it work
how are you going it's early I am well
and I'm ready to fight the internet we
do not acknowledge them but you know who
them are I like to acknowledge them so
are we acknowledging that I think we're
just saying them but we're not
specifying them but you're filling in
the blanket it's a mad libs intro today
please go ahead leave a like that would
mean the world tell us your thoughts
down below what you thought of this
trailer
oh boy and also you just invited The
Piano Guys
the threshold oh and also uh today's
video is indeed sponsored by G fuel
gonna talk more about them after the
trailer reaction specifically because I
wanted to give a very personal shout out
to how they have really helped change my
lifestyle I've seen a good amount of you
guys commenting the comment boxes about
how oh girl you look like you're getting
in better shape well you know what do
you feel has been a big part of that
change for me no just an overall
lifestyle change for me as well so yeah
more on them after the reaction let's
get into it people
Captain Rambo
what the hell are you doing Sabers
during the jump Point perimeter
I'm gonna get you some readings Fury
hello
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
she got villani too
whoa
where's Captain Rambo
[Music]
whoa
uh the Miss Marvel postcard
I think it's the first time with post
credits but in the trailer
what universe is this is this 606 is it
nine nine nine nine
we're looking I can't wait to see
okay so our powers all right angles
energy and you I could totally show you
oh my oh wow hi
where's our daughter wherever you are
oh no
forking hey
[Laughter]
it's a galactic Planet
planetary intergalactic
the planet the musical Planet yeah
there's multiples working wow there must
be there's a whole race of them yeah
that fight
we're not a team
you're a superhero pose on
why are they fighting each other there
awesome awesome sauce girls get it done
well that looked like a lot of fun all
right well we're gonna go through this
trailer frame by frame in just a second
but overall yeah it looks like it's
actually look looks genuinely fun if
that makes sense you know not like the
safe word fun it looks like oh it seems
like everyone on screen is having like a
really good time and I'm most excited
for Iman villani a really quick job what
you think I'm excited as well this I
mean the trio of them is the heart and
soul of you know what makes this look so
funny Iman villani is a treasure and I
think leading with fun after the
response to the first movie is a good
direction to head in for this to build
good yeah I think it's the first time
we've seen a post-credits scene from a
show in a trailer so I think it's really
smart to show that connection if you
didn't watch the show if you've just
been at the movies but it's also I think
the tone is really smart especially
after they've moved the movie to
November I think it's smart to show
confidence like this is a big Sci-Fi
Action comedy have a bold fun funny
trailer as opposed to like just a teaser
I think with smart out of the gates
wrong the implications do seem like they
could factor into the bigger part of the
Multiverse Saga like I feel like this
could lead to some incursion events at
the same time it does feel like it's
really focused on the immediate plot and
not just setting up the future but guys
before that I do want to play my my
little special solo ad thank you to G
fuel for sponsoring this video now guys
G fuel is by far the easiest thing for
me to shout out on this channel reason
why is because g-fuel plain and simple
no if Sans or buts it has been a part of
my lifestyle for several months now you
guys might have noticed you might see me
drinking G fuel quite a lot on this
channel on videos that are not sponsored
by G fuel it's just my main choice of
Beverage to help keep me hydrated or
help keep me awake and alert now I
really love the the very fortunate very
blessed position that we're in that we
get to make a living doing something as
weird as this however sometimes there
could be a lot of very early mornings
and sometimes obnoxious late nights
sometimes there's all Niners that are
being pulled to give you an idea last
week with everything that was coming out
everything I had to prep for YouTube and
page patreon I was averaging like two to
four hours of sleep at night now the
reason I'm bringing that up is because
when Greg is tired on camera I know
those comments Greg looks sad Greg looks
depressed Greg looks bored with the
channel he's over it when really a lot
of times I'm just tired and I just might
not be as expressive in that moment
that's why having a beverage like G fuel
I really love because it helps keep me
focused helps keep me alert helps keep
me awake and best part is it doesn't
give me like some spiked up Pulse or
even lead to some gnarly crash ever the
other thing I want to talk about too is
a lot of you guys have been so kind as
to point out and Yeah it feels like a
weirdly self-conscious talking about it
but a lot of you guys have pointed out
that hey look like you're getting better
shape crack and I have half a month and
a half and I've been taking dieting and
exercise a little bit more serious again
so thank you to all those super kind
comments I've seen coming in and a big
part of my fitness regime is
implementing g-fuel into my life like I
enjoy getting the can out of the fridge
there's a nice convenience to that when
filming on camera or giving it to a one
of the many people who come on this
channel but the reason I've been
clutching onto this blender bottle is
because when it comes to working out I
prefer for the powder they got a lot of
different flavors and I just use one
scoop of G fuel now they're not
advertised as a pre-workout but I
personally use it as my pre-worked out
if I'm out of cans like I currently am
right now I can just make some powder in
the water get the same exact flavor and
effect sometimes if I'm not planning on
working out but I still want to you know
have a good wake me up I will just mix
some g-fuel into like a a morning shake
or something like that also after I
worked out and especially on days that I
do cardio like today I use their
hydration powder which I can either take
on its own or I can mix it in with some
after workout shake so yeah guys if you
are interested you can use our promo
code in the description box and pin
comment reject Nation for 20 off select
tubs and on top of that too it is a
great way to support the channel I said
this to my G fuel rep many times I love
to be partnered with them forever
however even if a partnership happened
to fall through happens sometimes I
would still be a loyal customer plain
and simple so thank you g fuel again
back to the video okay so at the very
beginning of this trailer saying saber
space station not sword not Shield saber
what is saber koi I'm gonna own
something went to Google it and I feel
better because it didn't immediately pop
up because I was like do I just not know
an entire organization the internet's
with me and I'll just own that
embarrassing moment live uh yeah I'm
assuming it's Shield uh you know is the
S and then maybe it's it's new to the
MCU or it is like a more obscure space
designation I don't know and doesn't
immediately come up on Google but I
didn't know this right away I'll own
that and it looks like this is probably
the space station where Nick Fury has
been camping I know with the Scrolls am
I right about this yeah did they saber
at the end of the Nick Fury commentary I
don't remember that name ever popping up
I'm wondering how this is going to
factor into secret invasion is this like
revealing that Nick Fury survives secret
Invasion even though the trailer is
saying
will Nick Fury die in the events of
secret information
unless he's never on earth and the
skrull in secret Invasion dies that we
think is him because he's clearly in
space so here we go Star Trek and no it
does look very Star Trek yeah all on
that oh yeah do you have any idea who
these people are koi vague henchmen in
space no you're supposed to know
everything well this blue guy is clearly
commissary 67 from Avengers
well yeah I do like the way this set
looks because this looks like a studio
set and I think that's very purposeful I
feel like this set is supposed to look
like a Star Trek 60 set like supposed to
look a little cheap well the most part
it feels like that doesn't look like
Kubrick's move Landing fake
but the movie feels like it's supposed
to be very stylized and that seems
intentional if you've seen Candyman yet
acosta's film like the way it's shot at
all of her choices are very visually
aesthetic and you can even see that in
the mom mondalani shot when she's
pivoting around do you have a practical
camera turn into Nick Fury like a lot of
that spiral imagery reminds me of her
directing style so I'd say this
aesthetic is all very intentional
Victoria Alonso directs the movies not
whoever's not hot
this time around I'll admit when this
moment came up on screen too of seeing
Kamala Khan family that got me really
excited because they were there I mean
yes Monica Rambo also introduced via
television show but we spent so much
time with the Khan family in in the Miss
Marvel series that it was really
exciting like oh my God they're the puck
from the tell that from the television
Vibe into the big screen live action to
crossing over with this gave me that
crossover event excitement in a weirder
way because it's not as obvious or as
apparent as like Avengers crossing over
as soon like the con families that's
pretty cool yeah red dagger looks like
is that him in the bottom left there I
don't think so I think that's just some
guy there's not just gonna be a guy at
dinner why is he got a thing oh he's
tied up here
he was blurry that's not really a bad
guy it seemed oh this must have happened
when the switcheroo already occurred
yeah to fight whoever came over here
yeah because remember red dagger had the
finger on his face yeah uh but this is
not him I do like the cinematography a
lot more looking at these visuals
because there's something more striking
about it it doesn't look like overly
blown out or like inexpensive really
bright yeah yeah but it still maintains
a certain kind of colorfulness that I
feel like they get dogged for not having
so I'm hoping that maybe this is a more
vibrant looking movie and totally Miss
Marvel is a very vibrant character in
the comics and in her show and it's good
to see Captain Marvel get to play in
that because I think that suits Brie
Larson's take more I wonder will this be
the first time the um Monica Rambo and
Carol Danville are reuniting in this
scene right here ah that'd be
interesting could be a big old family
love the new suit for Captain Marvel by
the way I know looks great looks
fantastic there's a bit of a Charlie's
Angels vibe in this sense of you got
these three women and then you got Nick
Fury who's like a Bosley
the next mission is off Planet that's
what life I'm getting at least yeah no
totally I'm sure that's that was one of
the touchstones for this and it
certainly seems like they're reaching
back yeah into like Kick-Ass uh girl
team you know properties as well as just
maybe even like old TV and things like
that there is like a spunky kind of
older quality and tone to this also Nick
Fury's relationship to Captain Marvel
she's a captain Tiana Paris is playing a
she's at least a lieutenant right Monica
Rambo and then you've got a literal
child in a monthly so it's gonna be fun
to see those different hierarchies this
thing when they're all switch every time
they use their what the Bengal they just
start uh love the return of the floor
again yes give me a toy
this doesn't really tell you what the
exact plot of the movie is like it's
telling you the circumstances of what's
going on with our Trio here as you go a
little bit further into the trailer
which does seem to have like a bit of a
mix of a typical Marvel film at a
Guardians of the Galaxy repair which is
not your typical Marvel film
um but as you go further into it I am
wondering if some of this will be
dealing with the repercussions of the
events of Captain Marvel one with
defeating what what what is her name not
not sorcerer supreme
Supreme sovereignty Supreme whatever
what is the freaking name
um oh I was like this person
Sovereign
that it has to be dealing with the
events of Captain Marvel one I think
it's gonna be a a mix of what Captain
Marvel 1 landed at but mainly to me
secret Invasion I think something
happens in secret Invasion maybe it's
the crew scroll war is started maybe
something happens why are they off
Planet why are they traveling what do
they have to find or do I'm not saying
it's necessarily Creek or scroll but
something happens in secret Invasion I
think that launches this it's kind of
cool to see that secret invasion is a
sequel to Captain Marvel for Nick Fury
and this is a sequel to Captain Marvel
for Carol Danvers yeah and we haven't
seen her since One Division we haven't
seen Monica Rambo so it's also tying
into where she's been because time must
have passed yeah
this looks like if James Gunn did a
Bollywood dance number yes which is
exactly what a pretty large set of her
comfort zone and then into That Bouncy
Carol Danvers that everyone's hoping to
find so timing wise you got guardians in
May you've got secret invasion in June
you've got this in November I think it's
a good thing to tie that guardian's
flavor into the cosmic universe and
forward
I don't know who these people are a lot
of cats there are looks of it that
remind me of like Thor Ragnarok this is
when though that's what I was thinking
very Ragnarok to me this is when the
lighting starts to look like yeah a
Marvel movie oh this person this is I
think the main bad guy I don't know the
main bad guy's name she's got um yeah
she's gonna accuse people so yeah it is
decree yeah that makes sense they're
blue yeah yeah so that guy looks just
like Ronan right behind her oh yeah also
that yeah I think secret invasion is
definitely and I think that is a Cree
scroll War moment because that is
definitely a Cree is this Ronin no it
looks like just another guy who's a
priestess yeah okay so the henchmen that
we're attacking
um Monica earlier were Cree at least at
least that one guy in the front you
could judge me for not no one from
Avengers 67 they've got different
complexions some of them are blue some
of them are are human toned
and why are they fighting each other
that is the question I'm really curious
about like what causes that it's also
they're not changing Powers there so
this must be like in the third act maybe
they've solved it she also has her own
the accuser staff at one point here
so it makes me think that maybe there's
a possession maybe something happens
where see like that's definitely
right is that the staff I mean yeah it
looks like it the only way to make her
likeable to everyone was to make her
evil all right guys that was a fun
trailer I enjoyed it I hope that this is
good likewise what did you all think I
give this trailer and an 8.5 out of 10.
I'm right there with you I was going to
say 0.7 I'm wondering I'm wondering if
we're Polaris because of the saber thing
that I can't figure out that's gonna vex
me until I get on my phone and look at
all the saber things in Marvel I give it
a 7.98 oh it's pretty good sexist oh
it's a pretty good trailer but you know
there could be even more things to
discover that'll excite me that much
further I'll just give room for
improvement man I wish we had another 30
seconds so it's a full tree
all righty guys well thank you so much
for being here thinking to G Phil for
sponsoring we'll catch y'all soon
[Music]